welcome to this video again sue Shanghai
double 08 yes that's always a tough
opponent let's see what we get here and
I confess I did not upload the game
before that I was a totally one-sided
game and then i blundered into a maid
and I I made I mean I mean I got made it
right and I was just cruisin so badly i
I couldn't upload that and I didn't want
to edit edit the video i didn't i didn't
feel like it so i had to scratch this
recording and this is funny what he's
doing he s he's running into the same
funky line that i did once in a
tournament game yeah she wanted it looks
it looks very strange but this is um
this is a funny inaccurate move water
okay well why does not losing off or
anything he just has to hook in chief
woman so let's see where I am I going to
a five maybe now the rook seems that
seems very funky but it's not yet
decided or anything this this game okay
what am I going to do here knight c6
maybe looks looks active but he has a 3m
hmm a three also would have been
interesting do I have 94 in this
position it takes eat eggs and if the
night moves i have d3 is this something
94 he takes eat eggs let's go for that
plane looks funky making some use of my
specific piece placement maybe that was
something that i should have looked at
hmm and I definitely should have checked
this a little bit at least yeah now no
takes this Bishop takes and this is not
going to work what a shame take cake 94
so my idea was not working at all great
anyway to make this tricky at least is
94 that's the worst of it that's the
worst part which is immediately
immediately killing it okay from such a
nice opening position I really think
that this is quite nice there with the
rukon gee 190 for now is unfortunately
immediately trading stuff always check
and maybe I can somehow fight a little
bit there I don't know his king is still
a bit insecure but it's never never
going to be enough objectively yeah but
way is he going if he takes takes I have
d3 and Bishop g4 ideas how maybe that
isn't that that is not so easy
it's not that easy quite remarkably I
just blend it here but it's not so easy
to win
yeah I understand it's kind of strange
but we check their what to see going to
play Knight f6 Q in f6 that's not so
clear it really isn't the d3 and Bishop
g4 ideas are very very problematic and
e4 hangs and if it goes f3 this desti
three okay here at Bishop f5 I thought
Bishop f5 maybe then f3
f3 is ready to Castle long maybe three
we should be 5f three so no technique
there somewhere that looks it looks like
there should be some tactic can also
play these three here for Queen B to not
sure that this is going to lead to much
if I take their Bishop takes Bishop g4
is also interesting
I'm not sure it was it was too tough
really and this is closed in the short
time f 3 f f 5 that was my idea and then
he had no yes I can play we should be
three I can't I don't think yes he can
take h7 there that looks to neds looks
that doesn't look right and I'm
threatening Bishop e2 when I'm
preventing long castling this was
important
ha amazingly difficult at least at least
in my in my view maybe I'm just too bad
a calculator here this seems this seems
very daring to me grabbing grabbing this
okay Driggs yeah there's no direct
refutation I can take their queen bee
five queen bee five-time 183 43 we
should be three though I can take the
five then t3 check all right it's got
Queen d2 maybe 50 seconds we have equal
material believe it or not
yeah a little bit behind on the clock
there
check ya know I'm a pulling up there
that's nice check check
and now I'm going up with my king here
okay no let better not this is better
doing this first check I'm just
promoting check check
check check check check check ah
terrible technique what am i doing yeah
mate last possible moment I was terrible
taking 15 years with the Queen but
woohoo yeah I was such a roller coaster
game yeah this was a bit a little bit of
a sweet revenge I also lost one game
where i blundered apiece where he
blundered a piece against me and now it
was kind of yeah it was kind of similar
yeah they came I simply simply did not
think here 96 I should take on deform
something like that and play this
position like this is what the comp is
suggesting being very simple-minded
they're taking on default possible yeah
this is just not working probably ok
well the computer actually gives it a
sequel I'm getting crazy am I and then
so that wasn't a blunder it is actually
working unbelievable computer is playing
Queen a six though I went to Queen B 6
yeah it was said was just pure luck
there but the next the next moves the
bishop computer wants to do this funny
Bishop f5 f3 and Tia I didn't really
have an idea what to do rooty eight I
was thinking he would castleman but rook
t5 is actually given us great by the
comp giving me more than enough
compensation
hey the position looks nice but it's a
piece um yeah maybe maybe computers
probably reliable here and this is
probably not so great still equal check
now TX over the computer wants to take
with the route back that's funky rupee
80 interesting count gives this and as a
nine according this equal it's a cool
evaluation equal and Kim so this back
yeah Bishop e3 is stronger I suspected
that much Quincy five years still
somehow continuing but why does of
course better here yeah that's better
for white and with that we are entering
into something about equal yeah I didn't
play well but I was kind of somewhere I
was thinking I was largely down to time
but I wasn't this was better getting not
that one getting this in possibly
alright what the crazy game okay well
thanks for watching